welcome back to PEB un sensitive we all
know Müller yogurts these creamy treats
with crunchy or fruity bits in your
corner other in Delicious Brands are
available apparently all yogurts are
evil they're murderous a vegan charity
has released an ad about them that will
give you nightmares a warning you might
find this disturbing new from killer
yogurts the umbilical cord
flavor produced with only the finest
ingredients the stolen milk of grieving
mothers taste the torment in every
mouthful blended with
brutality be
complic with killer
yogurt well I'm joining now by the
director of the charity Viva who made
the ACT Juliet gatle well Juliet I've
got to be honest that's one of the most
disgusting things I think I've ever had
to watch it's also one of the most
disingenuous it's a yogurt for goodness
sake why are you making ads like that
about a yogurt I'm sorry I don't believe
that that's the most dis disgusting
thing in your editorial career that you
pretty much one of them I got to be
honest I'm sorry it's a pantomime style
it's obviously a parody it's obviously
fake blood um you know over three
million people saw it um and well the
point is we went into an investigated
dairy farm
and blew apart the notion that these
animals are in idle most one one in five
of the animals and supplying people like
that were zero Grays this means they
never saw a blade of grass and I went so
I went in myself to check this out and
they're in filthy conditions the male
carves taken away and shot or knifed in
the throat because they don't produce
milk the mothers when their milk
production went down killed so there's a
lot of death in the D let me ask you let
me ask you let me ask you this what do
you think happens in the wild
how do you think animals
eat what species are you talking about
well you're very you're very concerned
about the protection of animals but if
you go to the African bush animals eat
each other all day long in the most
Savage primeval way why aren't you
campaigning about that why don't you
going to protect animals from other
animals yeah listen my degree zoology I
know quite a lot about animals and they
are not and they not my Tik Tok Fe all I
see all day are lions destroying
gazelle's come on they're not which is's
a bit more gory than that they're not
farmed they're not Factory farmed these
animals never see sunlight they never
graze a blade of grass it's obscene I
don't think even you would agree with
that well I always my problem with
vegans is this I me I bet you're a you
probably like almonds do you oh no
you're not going to do the Almond
avocado with me no this is B ask do this
is boring it may be boring I actually
find the vegan assault on Meed is boring
so do you eat avocados and armor I'm not
assaulting do you eat them anybody do
you eat them I eat them from Spain so
you do you eat avocados because the
issues that you talk about you drink
what kind of milk do you drink you're
talking about the murder kind of milk
you drink you talk about the murder
Sawyer Sawyer okay yeah you talk about
the murder of bees in other interviews
yes because vegans don't care but you
don't care about the billions of carves
and chicks and piglets so you're a
complete hypocrite not you are P the
Hypocrites are the vegans who Munch away
on armonds and and the avocados and
stuff they don't of a damn about
billions of bees getting annihilated the
bees are the little guys and I have this
conversation time because that's the
hypocrisy I don't care obsessed with
this because you think it catches I am a
proud and happy meat and
yog when you try and make out this
yogurt is the most evil thing that
anyone in the world I think your bunkers
we're in a six mass extinction we're
living it now you're behaving like a
news anchor and I'm in the what you're
behaving like a news anchor on the film
don't look up when the six the last
Extinction you're deflecting all the
time from the world is not going to end
because trying to deflect because I eat
a yogurt animals are Factory farmed
you're trying to deflect from the fact
veganism protects the environment we're
still here we are but how much longer
have we got you've got kids you must
care about the climate crisis I let my
kids eat meat I let them eat yogurt and
you know what I don't think it's evil
you must care about the climate crisis
and you must be aware that the
University of Oxford has specifically
stated a vegan diet it protects the
envirment you rces you said you eat your
you said you got you eat almonds
avocados in Spain which one from Spain
which one both I don't eat almonds how
do they get avoc how do they get here
Boat Boat really you sure yes I am sure
you sure I am absolutely sure really and
how do you think most vegans get most of
their armor avocados from California and
how do you think mosters get their they
don't get them from a boat they get them
on planes and they get them on planes
which guzzle up the environment you eat
avocados yes but you care about all
these millions of bees being no I care
about your hypocrisy about the little
guys rubbish most bees are killed
because of overuse of pesticides most
overuse of pesticides is due to the way
that the land
form
to for farm animals that is not true
you're talking most of the bees get
killed in the pollination process and by
the way after they get killed you vegans
get all your armors avocados flown over
on these gas guzzling planes and my
point is I like to fly I like to eat
meat I like to eat yogurts I'm just fed
up with vegans trying to shame you for
it when you're all such Hypocrites when
it comes to the bees no you're not you
against factory farming if you went
inside the Farms that I've been inside
and the reason that I set up Viva the
state of the animals that I've seen them
in pigs dying in front of me if this
makes me evil you would not this makes
me evil I am happy to be evil it's
disgusting it's delici
love to see you that's it from me
whatever you're up to keep it
creamy